alors il va être
vous vous souvenez ton accordéon me
fatiguent il va être si tu jouais plutôt
de la clarinette et maintenant mais ça
n'a rien changé dit musulman de
l'accordéon maintenant c'est gautier qui
fait vos clips alors quel effet ça fait
d'être devenu
une star débrancher après avoir été
critiqué il ya 20 ans par par antoine
c'est à dire que critiquer critiquer si
tu es notre gérant salma non ça m'a
donné un tout petit peu en haut des
parties mon dieu la critique il faut la
prendre il faut la lire il faut la
laisser de côté il faut en prendre
non toujours là en soi n'est plus là
lien bien c est ce qu on pourrait dire
que les unes voyage je pourrai dire que
j'ai quand même continué et que la
portion a toujours marché
alors quand vous étiez petit voulais
être concertiste épicé vos parents qui
vous ont dit finalement tu devrais jouer
de l'accordéon parce que l'accordéon
quand même on meurt pas de faim quand on
joue de l'accordéon l'un est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous donneriez la moitié
de votre carrière l'accordéoniste pour
une carrière de concertiste et non je
referais la change vous referiez la
méfiance une monnaie même chose c'est à
dire que quand mes parents m'ont demandé
de laisser les études classiques de
continuer après le conservatoire
d'apprendre la formule est sûre j'ai
pleuré pendant trois ans on peut dire
trois ans je ne pouvais il est
impossible d'entendre une notes de piano
à la radio car j'ai eu c'était un
effondrement
j'avais perdu un amour un amour très
cher et qui n'a jamais pu mourir
d'ailleurs qui est toujours dans mon
coeur c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
enregistrer un disque l'avait justement
leur parlons-en surréaliste de classe et
pianiste classique au piano avec du lys
du crâne à dos albeniz des études de
l'iss et à la cour d euros dont l'autre
face il ya dix ans de scarlatti
du ski lydie dattas est pareil quand on
est habile de cinq mois on veut jouer de
l'accordéon on peut jouer du piano
l'étape habile à dire sa demande le
travail intense
c'est une discipline que l'on doit
s'imposer une discipline je dirais
réduite à 50 60 % quand un amour quand
on fait les choses et création avec
amour
donc c'est un travail constant est ce
que j'ai dit et moi je travaille
beaucoup mais c'est vrai je viens mais
c'est du made si son travail c'est une
légende ça et moi je connais les plus
grands travail mais ils donnent pas
toujours l'impression d'être rasées il a
été très disponible pour quelqu'un qui
travaille autant que je vais te coucher
à 6 heures du matin j'ai perçu 100 km
ville et cela vous sortez un livre c'est
finalement sur ma carrière c'est pas
choquant du format 10 ans que l'on me
demande et s'est fâché car non non
c'était sublime acquis ar oui c'est
tellement de travail intense donc
et la musique il ya une chose qui soit
solide il faut se remettre en question
tous les jours
tous les jours on ne sait jamais vous
avez le trac quand vous montez sur scène
vous êtes toujours le trac
j'essaie de devait être ce trac parce
que si vous voulez si on me demande de
compter jusqu'à 2100 mhz arrêté c'est
une image sur scène je compterai jusqu'à
fin mai oui voilà alors non que le reste
il faut jouer toujours beaucoup plus
fort que le programme que l'on
l'exécutant public et ça je pensais que
un peu on peut maîtriser pour maîtriser
bien sûr l'instrument et simplement
toute une vie et qu'est ce vous faites
quand que le trac quand vous avez un peu
le travail fait quoi une coupe de
champagne non et non ah non surtout pas
surtout pas ça veut pas alors je vais
vous poser une question qui nous brûle
les lèvres c'est que vous avez joué dans
une fête organisée par couscous clan
actuelle à la cartoucherie avec mort et
mory kanté est ce que c'est une prise de
position politique est-ce que vous
est-ce que c'est une prise de position
finalement en faveur du mélange les
les rousses avec les miliciens donc de
l'amour beaucoup d'amour aux rf est un
musicien prendre vouloir tirer derrière
un quant à nous c'est la poésie c'est un
travail bien sûr j'ai dû tout à l'heure
et lorsqu'on m'a proposé de faire cette
émission la cartoucherie de vincennes
avec des moments où la mortalité avec la
rade et cetera c'est une idée qui m'a
séduite par ce que je pense moi bien sûr
le musicien est là pour dire que l'on
peut s'attendre et n'y a pas que le
musicien bien entendu - c'est normal le
logiciel est là pour tendre pour tendre
la main pour donner les jolies dabo est
alors plus de vent que cette soirée là
et je veux policiers ou pas alors étant
donné que celui qui joue de la harpe
indienne le dis je ne peux pas
enregistrés en je ne peux pas jouer dans
plusieurs pions qu'il faut jouer ça me
donne mal j'arrive au foot et lorsque ce
sera à vous de vous exprimer je ferai le
passé mon orchestre en mi bémol tout le
monde durant mi bémol et vous pourrez
vous êtes se sent bien et nous avons
joué alors finalement ça a été une
improvisation
pendant les quatre heures de temps et
j'ai passé une soirée jeux vous dire
qu'il marquera dans ma carrière
nous avons joué avec beaucoup d'amour et
nous sommes relayés nous sommes tendus
la main et c'est là quelque chose qui
peut faire faut lui ment au long du
match et de vous faire plaisir ça de
logique de voir née yvette horner aller
jouer avec mory kante avec des musiciens
africains arabes
trèbes où je trouve je parle pas
tellement bien de la musique et danse
joue très bien mais dès mardi parce
qu'il va donner à jéricho l'heure si on
pouvait parler delà de la politique de
la même façon qu'elle devient illico
leur segment lunaire que ce jour là donc
il y avait tellement de mitterrand il
est venu avec eux
avec l'appelant et qui ont trouvé cette
soirée du viande
je m'excuse des mômes un exceptionnel
que c'était comme ça fait plaisir d'en
faire une soirée au mois d'octobre avec
plusieurs races ou nous tendrons l'année
on peut le faire voir au monde que c'est
l'amour qu'il faut c'est d'amour chaleur
chaleur humaine et est importante on ne
peut pas vivre sans l'amour on peut pas
vivre son amitié voulu bannir 570 vrai
ça n'existe pas c'est fondamental et
j'étais très heureux c'était je vous
dise j'ai été séduite et pas cette idée
et je leur ferai avec grand plaisir est
vous avez été élevé chez les bonnes
soeurs
est ce que vous êtes toujours croyants
si ces croyants se traduit comment vous
faites une prière avant montrer sur
scène non non traduit comment on n'a pas
besoin de fréquenter l'église a fait un
bond c'est moi qui le pense j'ai
peut-être une erreur
eh bien on peut très bien être voire
croyant on peut prier partout donc je
sais pas de frais hier une rentrée mais
je suis croyant je crois je suis pas
pratiquante parce que le temps mais
n'empêche
mais il ya une forme si vous voulez des
pratiques et dans la croyance
donc je pense que je n'ai peut-être pas
besoin d'aller à l'église tous les
dimanches au lendemain vous êtes croyant
je crois quelques quelques existence de
la divinité ou à l'ordre des choses à
l'ordre du monde
oui je ne suis pas par forcément engagée
dans une religion
et je pense aussi qu'il ya un tronc
commun toutes les religions où il suit
cette forme dont parle si bien yvette
c'est à dire la richesse l'humanité
voilà le genre voilà les yeux moi je
trouve ça il n'y a pas plusieurs
deviennent acteurs et plusieurs façons
d'y arriver y en a qu'un là cette
divinité mobilité qui bien sûr je pense
qu on ne peut pas dire voilà c'est bon
dieu est à coloniser succès sur un
recours non il ya un seul but merci
interpréter le comme vous voudrez on
sera vite vous entendre dire les choses
si importante dans un endroit où on
s'amuse aussi merci beaucoup